what exactly is the purpose of the
protest
uh two things to end the mandates on
vaccinations because and by the way I'm
vaccinated I'm fully vaccinated and I
usually get the flu vaccine every year
so when we're doing the intvax thing
sorry that's not us
uh so to end the vaccine mandates and
allow people the freedom of choice
whether we agree or disagree with that
choice it's their freedom of choice
and to end the um the it's called the
arrive can it's a covid passport app
similar to what the parent the provinces
have rolled out which they're now uh
rolling back
and this app goes on your phone and well
it tracks you it has your covet health
status on your phone
welcome to the Michaela Peterson podcast
this is an emergency episode it's an
interview with one of the leaders of the
Canadian trucker Convoy I tried to ask
neutral questions that every Canadian
might be interested in and people
outside of Canada for that matter it was
recorded today I hope this helped
clarify the situation in Canada for
people
a quick word from the sponsor of this
episode dad and I are on tour and
nordvpn is a lifesaver with the state of
the world at the moment you can't be too
careful about your data nordvpn is the
fastest VPN in the world it keeps your
data safe and Anonymous and nobody gets
to tell you what you can or can't watch
I can't recommend them enough they have
an exclusive offer for my listeners grab
your exclusive Nord VPN deal by going to
nordvpn.com
tmpp like the Michaela Peterson podcast
tmpp or use the code tmpp to get a huge
discount off your nordvpn plan plus one
additional month for free plus a bonus
gift it completely risk-free with nord's
30-day money-back guarantee enjoy this
episode
[Music]
welcome to my podcast
well thank you thank you for having me I
really wanted to talk to you to get you
on to address a whole bunch of questions
that I think
Canadians and people across the world
who are watching what's going on in
Ottawa with the trucker protest I'm
hoping to have you address a whole bunch
of those questions so I want to get
through as many of these as you have
time for sure of course so first off who
are you
uh I'm just some guy who owns a truck my
name is Benjamin dictor I am I guess the
spokesperson one of the board members of
the freedom Convoy and I was brought in
I guess 24 hours after uh they just
decided to go with this Chris and
Bridget and Tamara in Alberta uh
Tamara's been a friend of mine for many
years and uh she caught she did a she
they decided they're going to do a
convoy uh they're fed up they're if
you've been to Alberta recently you know
rural Alberta now looks like a third
world country and has for several years
now
and they've all had their lives and
their businesses crushed and they
decided this has got to end we have and
they're all about to many of them are
about to lose their uh their jobs
because I know at least one of them uh
couldn't actually get the coveted
vaccine because of some cardiovascular
problem it's none of my business I don't
ask
and uh you know she was going to lose
everything so they decided we have to do
something and make a statement let's go
to Ottawa we'll have a convoy let's do a
GoFundMe maybe we'll get you know 20
grand which is we'll cover some of the
gas
and
um let's go and see what happens and 24
hours later uh Tamara called me and said
you won't believe this we started this
our GoFundMe is at I think it was at 150
000 at that point
and she said uh do you mind coming on
board and helping with messaging and you
know helping organize this as much as
you can from your end
and I said yeah for for you anything no
problem and uh so we started and it just
grew organically from there
okay so you said it started partly
because this lady couldn't get
vaccinated because of health conditions
and she was at risk of losing or she was
going to lose her job because of it so
what exactly is the purpose of the
protest
uh two things to end the mandates on
vaccinations because and by the way I'm
vaccinated I'm fully vaccinated and I
usually get the flu vaccine every year
so when we're doing the iot vacs thing
sorry that's not us
uh so to end the vaccine mandates and
allow people the freedom of choice
whether we agree or disagree with that
choice it's their freedom of choice
and to end the um the it's called the
arrive can it's a covid passport app
similar to what the parent the provinces
have rolled out which they're now uh
rolling back
and this app goes on your phone and
while it tracks you it has your covet
health status on your phone
and you know I explained this on Tucker
Carlson and a couple of other shows that
I the first time I ever had to use it
was a week before all of this started I
was crossing the border from New York
into into Ontario
and I went to hold my phone up to the
Border agent with my QR code and I said
here you go I don't know what to do but
do what you need and he said to me no no
I don't need to see it uh and it's what
do you mean you don't need to see it he
said well when your phone gets within a
certain radius of our booth uh your
phone just pops up on my screen and all
your information is there already
so I I could see you before you even
came up to the booth
and it occurred to me at that point you
know everybody is so concerned you many
of our politicians posture the concern
of Data Tracking from uh big Tech firms
like Facebook and Twitter and whatnot
but at least with those platforms we can
opt out
but with the government we can't opt out
and what's going to be what's the next
step are they going to start rolling
that out to all government uh buildings
across the country like I don't know
maybe that's hyperbolic to think maybe
that's just too dystopian but it's
clearly a possibility at this point and
maybe every police cruiser will have a
receiver that could monitor each you
know covid app and phone vicinity
maybe it's a bit of a slippery slope
argument but we keep sliding down this
slope and nothing seems to be changing
so I think there's a cause for concern
maybe I'm crazy
I don't think you're crazy
you're welcome uh okay so let's I have a
whole bunch more questions for you but I
figure I might as well hit this at the
beginning what do you guys need to see
from the government in order to stop
protesting
well I mean ultimately we need to see
mandates removed and the passport uh app
dropped that's it it's pretty simple and
it's not like we are asking for
constitutional reforms or we're asking
for reparations or asking for any
dramatic change to our country we just
want things to be restored to the way
they are and we want the government to
get out of our phone like it's pretty
simple you know but we haven't even had
anybody from the government uh sit down
and meet with us which is interesting
you know Justin Trudeau can meet with
Joshua Boyle he can meet with Omar Qatar
but he can't meet with his working class
uh Transportation infrastructure who
have what I think are reasonable
grievances right and again it's not
about vaccines people can get vaccinated
people can quarantine at home as they
please that's fine but it should be
allowed up to the individual to choose
how they want to live their lives
okay so what does it look like on the
ground in Ottawa like what kind of
people are over there how many people
um how many I have no idea and it
changes day to day so on the weekends is
when things really uh Peak up
there seems to be a lot of people that
are coming from you know other
jurisdictions whether it's Quebec get a
lot of people coming from Quebec
Southern Ontario
and now people from coming from Vermont
and New York State and New Hampshire uh
coming to essentially the biggest block
party in Canada's history which we call
Trudeau's truck stop uh it's an amazing
Vibe uh you know some of my guys came
back it was the last night the night
before they came out to the hotel
because I'm a little bit incapacitated
so I can only go to you know a number of
meetings that in certain areas
and I said to them okay you guys hungry
I'll order dinner because there's five
or six of them here they're like oh no
we're stuffed like what do you mean like
everybody's barbecuing and throwing food
in our face so you walk around downtown
Ottawa every truck or every other you
know group has a little barbecue set up
they have Flags they're having taken
pictures with people they're trying to
spread this message of we're peaceful
and loving there's music going on like
if there were bouncy castles until I
think a couple days ago when Justin
Trudeau thought the bouncy castles were
a threat but the vibe has been amazing
it's like it's what I would imagine
without let's say the recreational drugs
it's what I imagine Woodstock would have
been like that sort of feel to it or
Wembley like those sorts of you know big
party atmospheres that's what it's like
in uh in downtown Ottawa it's amazing
and on top of that you know they talk
about oh the blockade wood block Aid
yeah there's a lot of trucks parked
illegally but we have an Ops team that
you know have experienced ex-military
ex-police that have established
emergency routes for emergency vehicles
traffic is Flowing around the city
slower there's no question but traffic
is still flowing we're trying to
minimize the disruption to people in the
city
and the local businesses who have stayed
open and violated the mayor's order to
close by the way so the mayor has issued
an order that any business that opens
will be issued a ticket for however much
money it is I don't know
but like the Shawarma shop like that
we've been going to just about every day
they said we have we are so thankful we
have never been so busy in three years
thank you everybody for what you're
doing and all the businesses that have
been staying open have been prospering
okay one of one of the criticisms I've
read about you guys in the media is that
this is a an alt-right
thing that's going on and a whole bunch
of the people who've gone to Canada
aren't even Canadian and so you
mentioned that there are people who are
coming in from Vermont in other areas so
how do you feel about that
well what happened to peace unity and
love what happened to open borders what
happened to we're all one world we're a
post-national state it's amazing how
they flip from that ideology to we need
hard borders now and Canadians are
completely different than Americans
um the Americans that are coming are
definitely a minority here uh I I would
I would guess the largest contingency
as separate from the truckers who have
come from the Prairies are people from
Quebec and that's been most amazing
seeing people from Quebec hanging out
with the people they're supposed to not
like from Alberta becoming friends
talking to each other through Google
translate and there's a couple of
pictures I took I took with a couple of
guys one guy was from Alberta one guy
was from Quebec and they're both holding
signs I had to take a picture one said
Freedom one said liberte they were
hanging out all day together standing
beside each other and just shaking
everybody's hands and hugging everybody
and whatever
and that's been the vibe the whole time
and you know I told this story a few
times of one of my friends who was here
helping with my leg after I broke it
which was fun uh she went to the Tim
Hortons to grab coffee in the morning
and she said you won't believe this I
just went to Tim Hortons and there's
these two guys and she's quite astute
there's these two guys in lying they
clearly are friends they didn't just
meet each other and they're talking and
they're laughing and they're pointing
and all this sort of stuff and they're
dressed as truckers so we assume they
are she says but they're talking to each
other through Google translate because
one is one was French and one I think
she said was from Saskatchewan or
Alberta so he couldn't communicate
directly but they formed a friendship
and some sort of bond and they're
starting to to try to learn a little bit
of French and a little bit of English
and it's just lovely it's it's the it's
the first real Unity I've seen in Canada
I mean you know we've all grown up with
this baggage of all the separatists here
and the Western separatists and nobody
likes each other and nothing could be
further from the truth When government
and the media get out of the way the
people unify and they learn they learn
to love each other and respect each
other's differences and that's what
we've seen all week
okay interesting well that's good to
hear
um what about all this news about
um I mean you see you get certain
pictures from the media and at the very
beginning there was some sort of statue
story there was like oh these people are
desecrating statues I call it hoax hate
okay okay so let's get into that a
little bit what was that about
uh well there were a few of them first
there was the um uh the Nazi flag that
we're alt right we're all Nazis and
whatever
uh I'd hate to tell Mr Trudeau I'm
Jewish and some of us still have
families in Mass graves in Europe so
that smear's not going to work Tamara is
a metis so she's from the Native
community so we're the racists but Mr
blackface he's The Virtuous one I think
it's it's clown world it's ridiculous
right yeah so somebody
um and this happens a lot in protests
where people you know age in
provocateurs or whatever you want to
call it they'll stage different things
right and they're so in this particular
case I mean nobody saw this until it was
all over all over the web somebody uh
unraveled uh a swastika a Nazi flag
and it was nowhere near any of like any
of the protests or any of the trucks or
whatever
it was some back corner of some Park and
there just happened to be somebody with
a ten thousand dollar cam a Canon camera
perfectly lined up for the shot you know
this was the money shot
so I don't imagine putting the sign
mandate Freedom uh on Terry Fox would
have been terribly offensive to uh the
man who required those basic freedoms to
run across the country which we can't do
right now right without being harassed
by the government so that was the second
hoax hate then there was the war
memorial hotel which was it started and
you can tell it's a hoax when they keep
changing the reason
so first it was a truck parked on the
war memorial no no truck parked on the
war memorial a truck parked in the spot
adjacent to the war memorial that the
CBC usually parks in at uh Memorial Day
events so perhaps they were upset one of
our trucks took their parking spot I
would be upset too right
um then the 24 hours or 48 hours later
it became somebody desecrated the uh
Tomb of the Unknown Soldier have no idea
how it was just the word desecrated no
specificity whatsoever
and then 24 hours after that it became
somebody urinated on the Tomb of the
Unknown Soldier or the war memorial
somebody took a picture it was a little
bit of a warmer day that day of uh a
snow bank that had water melting on the
bottom took a picture and that
apparently was urine I guess they
haven't realized that you know uh snow
melt at zero degrees but okay fine
so and what was interesting about that
is because you know they they're so
disconnected the uh I caught them I
don't call them the global Elites I call
them the global scavenger class they're
so disconnected from Regular People
they miscalculate one very basic
phenomenon we all know that most people
or sorry many people in trucking are
either veterans themselves or come from
veteran families so just the fact that
that narrative was out there upset them
hugely to the point that a bunch of them
got together
with some veteran truckers they grab
they got their shovels and equipment and
stuff they shoveled all the snow around
the war memorial cleaned it up better
than the city has ever done made sure
there was no Garber Journey that sort of
stuff they went and got bouquets of
flowers and they took a beautiful
picture of it somewhere it's somewhere
on the internet they lined the Tomb of
the Unknown Soldier with flowers and
then they they assigned a team that
would rotate shifts 24 7 to ensure
nobody would be desecrating the war
memorial or the two neon Soldier so
that's the reality of what had what went
on
okay yes that's definitely different
than what you're hearing about
mainstream media things are pretty crazy
let's call them Legacy Media they're not
mainstream they're Fringe media is what
they are okay
Legacy Media that's definitely more
accurate yeah
okay so
um let's see has there been any violence
uh not that I've seen I mean maybe the
kids playing on the bouncy castles are
considered violence because you know we
live in a word where words are violence
so who knows what uh the fake news media
defines violence but no no cops have
been injured no people have been injured
there's not been any scrum I mean again
these people so many of these people
come from veteran families they respect
the government they're not here to
overthrow the government because they
spend so much of their lives serving the
government
so it's a completely different you know
dynamic than perhaps you know the uh the
leftist militias that protest were their
anti-government that's not us
so no we haven't seen any of it and also
people are cognizant of being baited by
uh you know leftist activists into you
know January 6 like incident and
whatever and uh when nobody is taking
debate we understand
that uh this that's not what this is
about this is about a peaceful loving
protest and in many ways especially
people have been coming
from other jurisdictions it's been you
know a source of inspiration for younger
people to see how our process works and
how people can come together and unify
and want to talk to the government and
that the government works for us not the
other way around which is seems to be
the mindset of some people in our
political class
so
this is what I think happened from what
I've been reading but you can tell me
what actually happened but I believed I
believe the government officials tried
to hire tow trucks to come take out the
trucks and and they just said no I
thought that there's been an issue with
police arresting people so can you give
me a bit of background uh information on
the tow trucks police involvement and
how people are trying to get rid of the
protesters and how that hasn't been
working
okay so with the tote with let's start
with the policing and the arresting from
what I understand a handful of people
were arrested earlier in the week
oh sorry early in last week and it was
an intimidation tactic right charge them
with you know give them a ticket for
Mischief so let's drive him down to the
station give him a ticket for 150 and
that's kind of it from what I understand
it hasn't been anything more than that
I'm not sure and on police on the police
level we've had a we've actually had a
great relationship with the police on
the ground uh many of us not only do we
have people from military families but
many of us come from uh police families
like I have family and policing as well
so we kind of understand that the ground
level police officers are in a difficult
position and we have a common problem
and phenomenon in Canada where the upper
levels of policing the Chiefs and Deputy
Chiefs sometimes are often very
politicized they're more politicians
than they are police officers because
they're appointed by these ridiculous
Police Services boards by people who are
in political parties so that that's
that's something that has to end and be
fixed in our country that's another
issue
but uh so the relationship with police
has been great many of them have you
know there was a time when last week
they were taking the uh they're seizing
gas cans for people
and they thought that would anger us and
most of us maybe I have a dark sense of
humor I was on the floor laughing I
thought if you want an epic PR disaster
for police that's the way to do it take
fuel from people who just want to keep
themselves warm
and then the next day they threatened oh
we're gonna raid the you know we're
gonna raid all the the trucks and what
did they end up doing they found some
guys that were having bonfires to keep
themselves warm so they went and seized
their cord of wood and I thought yeah
stupid is gonna double down on stupid no
matter what and I was predicting a
little before then that I I told people
and a couple of speeches I gave I said
the chief of police of Ottawa I promise
you is going to take early retirement
and guess what he just announced 45
minutes ago that he has resigned his
position because he too is being put in
a position and being politicized by his
local city council who are very rabid
aggressive leftists that would have done
well during the Bolshevik era like some
of the rhetoric coming from them is not
becoming of anybody who holds office in
a liberal democracy it's quite
concerning
but even he I think it was too much for
even him and last week we had a senior
there was a senior uh staff sergeant
which if you know if you're in policing
you know that's a significant position a
senior staff sergeant also resigned his
position last week
wow okay
so what happened with the tow trucks
so with the tow trucks or you apologize
I forgot uh it's so funny there's so
many things happen
um the federal government and the city
government were calling just every tow
truck company that they could
even down to tow truck companies in a
New York state
and we had that tow truck company from
New York State reach out to us saying
yeah guess who called us for an order
they said they need a massive you know
Convoy of tow trucks to come for Ottawa
and they uh he said to us but don't
worry we like all the other tow truck
tow truck companies informed them that
we all have covid so we can't come and
then one tow truck company came from I
think it was Quebec I might be wrong
they showed up with a small Fleet of tow
trucks and they said yeah yeah sure
we'll come we'll show up they came and
they joined the protest it was
it because remember tow truck drivers
truck drivers these are people who work
through the night they see emergencies
on the road they see accidents they
sometimes help people in need who are
stranded so there's a little bit of a
Brotherhood that goes on behind them and
that that Bond seems to be as much
stronger than some government
bureaucratic demands go figure
hmm okay so what do you think is going
to happen like what happened recently
with Trudeau
it's interesting when he gave that press
conference uh I was watching that and I
thought like Theo Fury uh correctly uh I
think I agree with his assessment on
Twitter
he said well Trudeau has played his
final card
we'll see what happens next and when I
watch that press conference he said
something funny saying you know this
does not bring in the military and I
thought yeah because you tried last week
and the military told you to take a hike
and we know that because we have people
in the military
so Trudeau hasn't learned this Axiom a
general without an army is a fool and
that's the position he's in so now he's
you know gone all hysterical and even
people who are on you know the left side
of the political Spectrum but who you
know embraced the values of freedom and
I'm thinking the Canadian Liberties
Association for example and even the
Toronto Star today even they have said
okay this is way way overboard so he's
made himself look like a fool to his own
people and what are we gonna do we're
just gonna wait
wow so can you can you explain to any of
the people watching who don't know what
happened like what exactly happened what
are the emergency measure acts a bit of
background information there
um it's best to talk to a constitutional
lawyer about it but they started this on
the uh the city level they just declared
a state of emergency last last week
because you know a bunch of trucks are
illegally parked oh my God so it was so
funny and then Doug Ford uh you know Mr
Conservative Mr you know for the people
I think nuked his own political career
as well
um by trying to seize all our funds and
declaring a provincial state of
emergency
okay nothing changed because well
there's a bunch of trucks parts
illegally okay and now they're gonna try
on the federal level
okay what are they going to do can't
call in the military like he said he
doesn't this doesn't mean they will and
I don't think there's any appetite from
people in the military to go seize uh to
go arrest uh truckers people that they
may know from their communities
who are just parked illegally and having
a peaceful protest and have gone out of
their way to to demonstrate that it's
peaceful it's about Unity it's about
love and respect for one another and
we're just gonna sit here and wait so I
don't know what's Trudeau going to do
next we're going to get the Air Force to
do a flyover I mean that would be cool I
love planes so I'd love to see that but
what's that going to accomplish I don't
know
okay what happened with it so then this
is another thing so many things have
happened this is a very strange
situation but but well it's a strange
situation what happened to all the
donations
oh well we're just gonna have to
litigate it so
um the GoFundMe donations which was you
know the fake news media was first
reporting that it was frozen which it
wasn't you know the first day they're
saying all the donations were frozen and
I thought
don't you have eyes you can see the
progress bar of the donations go up
that's not frozen that's just gofundme's
regular procedure of you know filtering
any new campaign they do it to ensure
it's abiding by AML regulations and
international banking regulations and
they have to do their due diligence and
okay that's fine we understood that
right and again when we set up GoFundMe
everybody's like why did you go to
GoFundMe because we just thought we'd
get like 20 grand for gas like we didn't
realize that people would start using
this as a statement a political
statement to show their displeasure with
a political class which is what it's
become
so they eventually released uh you know
uh one point something million to US
which I'll get back to that in a second
and then they said we're just going to
keep the rest and give it to whatever
charity we want
so then in came uh Florida man Ron
DeSantis and the Attorney General of
Florida Ted Cruz a bunch of other people
saying uh yeah this is Criminal fraud
and this warns an investigation by the
U.S government
and then all of a sudden GoFundMe is
like no no we can give it back it was so
funny oh wow yeah so GoFundMe pathetic
so then they said okay we're gonna
refund everything lots of people have
gotten their refunds not everybody has
lots of people still have not wow and
maybe there's just a bottleneck on their
end so uh give send go then uh reached
out to us and we had some people working
with kiss and go they spoke to Jacob the
CEO and he was great he said we'll do
everything in our power to help rebuild
it and as soon as they launched the
freedom Convoy campaign on give send go
they got uh 5 million DDOS attacks per
hour
so somebody is very uh motivated and has
many Bots that were attacking that
website and they were overwhelmed by the
amount of by the number of donations
that were coming into the platform so
they just you know smaller company they
didn't have the infrastructure of
GoFundMe I couldn't even get on for
seven hours just to see it I wanted to
you know look at the messaging and stuff
it took me seven hours before the web
page would even pop up
and it already achieved one point in the
first 12 hours 1.5 million dollars in
donations and somebody told me we hit
4.5 million in like the first 24 or 36
hours something like that but I couldn't
tell because it would the the website
was so spotty right
so it got up to 8.5 million dollars and
then Doug Ford remember man of the
working class right yeah he's going to
go to court and try to block this
funding for all these truckers who need
to get fuel some of them are having
repair issues and all that sort of stuff
and Doug Ford was going to step on the
throat of The Working Man and have the
government seize any funds that came in
from Gibson go
so Gibson go then said okay we're gonna
stop any transfers they didn't have they
didn't transfer anything yet
we'll hold on to it while you guys go to
court and litigate it with uh with the
Ontario government which is the process
right now
so then the Bitcoin Community came out
because I have been a secret bitcoiner
for many many years
and they reached out they started uh a
drive trying to raise Bitcoin for the
truckers and that got up to 1.1 or 1.2
million dollars in a wallet somewhere to
go to the dot to the truckers and that
was primarily for legal funds is what
they want they want us to get I'm very
aggressive with the media and the
government that's been attacking us so
and that's going to happen it's just a
matter of time
so now Krista Friedland decided you know
you know it's the that philosophy they
have everything I don't like is Hitler
well everything I don't like is illegal
right so now Bitcoin is illegal
everything's illegal now like that's not
how our legal system works and
unfortunately they're probably going to
find that out the hard way so right now
we're just sitting back and waiting
okay let me see
what other questions do I have here for
you I think that covered most of it
um how how long do you like
what happens okay here's one what
happens if Trudeau invokes the emergency
measures Act Ontario Doug Ford has
already said
um he's okay with that he thinks it's
reasonable right so what happens if that
comes into play are you guys concerned
on the ground that people are going to
start getting arrested or bank accounts
Frozen
uh he's already invoked it remember he
did that last night that's what the
press conference was I thought that okay
then I have a question there and I don't
know anything about this so feel free to
explain but I thought that once you like
I thought that that was a suggestion and
then premiers of each province have to
agree
or is that done from what I understand
it's got to go to Parliament they got to
vote on it yeah right and that hasn't
happened yet
happened yet uh no I don't believe so
maybe that's what's happening today okay
I mean you can show you can see how
concerned I am yeah yeah I I can yeah
okay at some point they're going to
learn the people run the government they
work for us not the other way around and
it might be a hard lesson for them to
learn I mean I'm having people now to
suggest to me that Justin Trudeau might
have just laid the path for the end of
his political career and the government
to fall and the justification was look
at this it's from a political Insider
I'm friends with he said look at it this
way Jack meetsing keeps alienating
himself and the NDP from the Sikh
Community which we have so many Sikh
truck drivers here like they've been a
big part of the people who've been
feeding people like they're amazing
they're wonderful
um so he's now been alienating himself
even the the you know the most hardened
of NDP people understand the importance
of protesting because that's what they
do right like that's that's supposed to
be the party for it right that's right
that's right yeah so if Jack Meade Singh
is pulled by his own party and we know
he's uh he's not all that popular right
now
well then Trudeau is not going to have
the support for the for a minority
government then the government Falls and
I guess we go to an election like I'm
not sure because I guess a lot of this
is unprecedented I'm not a
constitutional expert so the more they
keep doubling down on this stupidity and
agitating things and escalating the
situation doesn't affect us we're just
parked in parking spots uh and on the
street uh but they're just shooting
themselves in the foot but like I said
in the very beginning
um you know extremists always double
down on one strategy they don't have
they don't seem to have the fortitude
and the observing ego to look at things
from the other perspective and say okay
well you know how can we maneuver around
this and get other people on our side
and negotiate like it's it's quite
shocking that somebody who was elected
with something like 19 to the Canadian
citizenry actually voted for Justin
Trudeau
uh are sitting there on their high horse
like we're in command like no no you're
not 80 of the people want nothing to do
with you and it's your job to come to
the table and talk to us and listen if
he does he will there shouldn't be much
of a conversation it's just dude end the
mandates and get rid of this passport
app that's it this is pretty simple
stuff like the solution like Peter Paul
ever said it's staring him right in the
face it's so easy and then they can
claim victory and they can say you know
our policies saved millions of people
and but now is the time to go back and
we didn't really want to do it and
unfortunately but it was the best thing
for the country and spin it however they
want that's fine we know they're going
to do that some people will believe them
some people won't who cares let me just
get back to what we should but they're
just holding on to this and it's just
crazy it makes no sense
okay well it I agree that this is absurd
I'm surprised actually I thought that
I thought sometime last week there would
be a roll out of well country uh
provinces around started dropping their
mandates right like Alberta said they
were going to drop it even Ontario said
things would go back to normal
eventually and so I'm surprised that at
a federal level
they're not just looking at all the
provinces and all the people and for all
the countries around the world oh I know
like yeah or the rest of the world
basically give or take Australia
Australia still benefit
and remember they said you know the
winter that's the most dangerous and
darkest time for covet okay well we're
we're not three weeks into this
uh we've had tens of thousands of people
here hugging parting together dancing
from all from various provinces in
Canada and I was in the hospital getting
my uh my leg reconstructed for surgery a
couple of days ago and I didn't see
Saint Elmo's Fire and you know masses of
bodies being rolled into the ICU and I
spoke to the people there and they said
yeah we're worried we don't want to have
any you know massive uh outbreaks in ICU
and I said how are things now they said
oh yeah it's quiet
okay so if it's not happening now then
we all know that uh this policy is the
wrong policy and it needs to be
abandoned and that's probably why the
rest of the world is doing so
okay wow is there anything else you want
to tell people and is there anywhere
people could go to support you guys even
though those initiatives keep getting
shut down
um yeah so they can go to my Twitter
which is bjdictor
uh D is so it's spelled b j d i c h c e
r
they go to Tamara's Twitter uh which is
Tamara under and Tamara underscore MVC
and it's very important the reason we've
been focusing on our personal uh
platforms is because we've also had to
navigate censorship online right
there is yeah that's it there's a um
there is uh Dave Rubin is setting up
freedom convoy.locals.com
so that's the next thing that's going to
be set up where you'll find information
to be able to donate whatever
the gifts and go is still there so
you'll be able to donate uh the tally
coin Drive I think there's another one
now set up in Bitcoin with the initial
one was uh put on hold since the
announcement from the Canadian
government but now there's another group
of people that set up tally coin so if
you just go to Freedom Convoy or
Canadian truckers you'll find uh
something again we're not so centralized
because of censorship
uh those three things but basically
monitor our oh and Quicken report is
another uh podcast uh it's another
Twitter account
that works with us at Tom is one of our
team and is one of the accounts that we
administer if you keep an eye on those
and myself on getter same BJ dictator
you'll get all the updates you need
we'll post links you'll get a sense of
where we're at and uh we're randomly
posting you know links to support if you
want to send money on give send go and
all that sort of stuff
um and we keep you know getting
everybody up to date with what's going
on that's really the best way again oh
and there is a freedom Convoy canada.com
website which again is being hacked or
hacked DDOS attacks and all that sort of
stuff so when it's up it's up when it's
not it's not
um and to everybody who's listening that
I just want to let you know this is not
about left or right you know I'm I'm not
a hardened uh right-wing person you know
I I like the I like the variation of the
Scott Adams uh approach which is you
know for me personally and I think this
explains a lot of us we like the goals
of the left we like the systems of the
right and we like the freedom of
Libertarians and somewhere
yeah and somewhere between all of that
that's where we all fit and that's why
we have people across the political
Spectrum like I did an interview last
week with this girl uh she's an
independent journalist because I've been
trying to do a lot of independent uh
journalists and she said to me I used to
be a separatist
until two weeks ago I bought my first
Canadian flag because I've never been so
proud
I hate it almost puts a tear in here you
make me cry yeah
so this is all about having our voices
heard
it's peaceful it's about love unity and
restoring our basic freedoms to choose
to do what we want in terms of bodily
autonomy we understand people are afraid
of the virus people should be free to
protect themselves and quarantine at
their will and do whatever they want
but the government has gone a little bit
out of control in terms of how they can
regulate our lives and like where does
it end am I not going to be able to ride
motorcycles anymore am I not going to be
able to eat fast food anymore like
that's where we're going with this so
it's inclusive of everybody we have you
know for those who care about racial
diversity I don't really care I care
about individuals but we do have people
from various communities from all over
the world like I mentioned the Sikh
Community has been a huge help in
feeding people because a lot of them in
trucking and uh yeah we the example of
the the Quebec qua faction and the
albertan faction everybody coming
together like this is I think it's not
attributed to us it's attributed to
everybody who got involved this is the
thirst for Canadian Unity that our
country has always needed and I think
think we finally got there we just need
to get our politicians to realize that's
what's happened
okay well thank you very much for coming
on
[Music]